[Music]
how are you greeted by cristian casares with
his news briefing from news now in
spanish deadly night in southern nevada
two people died in two accidents
on tuesday the first happened east of
downtown las vegas' near here and
frame art la  police said a
68-year-old man was hit by a
vehicle and died at the scene the
driver showed no signs of
intoxication while the second not
far away a teenager died after
being hit by a bus this
happened on overturning highway and
fences  wayne after 10 pm the
police said the victim was riding his
scooter and ran a red light
prior to the incident the driver also
showed no signs of intoxication this
morning another court was held for
the former rangers player  in ibrox
due to the vehicle accident where he
has 23-year-old centers lost his
life he is accused of driving under the
influence of toxic substances
resulting in death and  This time he
had been ordered to appear in court for failing
to take a white spirits test he
did not show up he should
show up on November 22nd and now
we go to the weather forecast
we will have a sunny day today
reaching 71 degrees we
will stay in those temperatures for  the
rest of the week, however, they will go down
basically reaching a little more to the
sixties around thanks day to
cristian casseres with super
informative news now el espanyol good day
[Music]